well this is a bubber i read the title
don't know any of the specifics that m2
will be delayed show up in the
notification bells from chris over at 3c
films i figured with news that
automatically when i read a title i'm a
little bit bummed out well let's at
least watch the video from the guy who
can at least make bummer of a news at
least a little bit fun that's one thing
that i could always rely on chris to do
is even if the news is not the most
positive i'm like well at least chris
can make it a more
a more enjoyable experience to learn the
information along the way of course give
our two cents as we go through this but
let's see what chris has to say
[Music]
you like following
me hi
hey
where you going
i'm talking to you
hi
where you going
[Laughter]
i'm coming for you i'm coming for you
hey guys thanks so much cooking on this
video my name is chris
i'm sick of this man last year around
this time we were hearing the word delay
about 50 times with every movie known to
man getting delayed then we finally
stepped into an era where we were
getting movies released left and right
it was even getting hard to keep up with
i was like what do i review what we're
going to be talking about here today
guys is that reports are coming out that
sony is seriously considering delaying
venom let there be carnage pushing it
back possibly the next year along with
some other other movies next year we're
gonna be breaking that down here along
with why this is happening again how
this is gonna affect spider-man no way
home but really just being pissed off
that this is happening once again come
and eat your guys opinions down below
how do you feel about delays looking to
be eminent again just because some
movies are not making the box office
dollars that they currently could are
you gonna be pissed off if we have to
wait another couple months for venom let
there be carnage and what will you do if
they touch spider-man no way
i'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
i mean if venom's getting delayed
spider-man has to be getting delayed
like it just seems 99 likely i was kind
of hoping some of these studios or
bigger films would wait to see how shang
chi does when it comes out uh september
3rd and especially if i'm tracking how
the second week would do with chongqi
and if they've already made the decision
to delay it i would not be surprised at
all it's more than likely spider-man no
way home will get delayed to 2022 which
is a bummer chris your little bits are
making this a lot more enjoyable
in the article they state in the case of
venom 2 it's another destination on the
release calendar first we heard january
then we heard october 15 i hear sony
hasn't decided what the new date is or
whether they'll continue to stay put on
september 24th essentially what they're
saying here is that they've heard
rumblings in their sources which hey
deadline is one of the most credible
news stations
so you got to kind of take their word
for it if they're hearing this that sony
has been looking at the box office for
like a movies like the suicide squad and
even the rising covet cases right now
and is thinking we're headed for another
slump where people are scared to go out
wanting to stay in their homes and
that's really going to affect the
potential box office potential for venom
let there be carnage and look they have
it here with those dates in mind whether
it's january or october ain't no way in
hell it's going to be october
[Laughter]
oh it's official big effing mouth oh
death you're so smart you're so cool
ain't no one hail's gonna be october
it's october oh no
what for now i was making the video for
you guys letting you know that they're
possibly thinking about moving venom let
there be garnish while i was editing the
video they announced it's been moved so
here we have the new date october 15th
of 2021
that's rare halloween kills
and i think it is a stupid decision man
because i'm telling you there is no way
in hell halloween kills is gonna be
moving out of that month because you
only release a halloween movie around
the halloween season so i don't care if
venom let there be carnage is actually
gonna beat them at the box office
they're still gonna take a major hit
from good old mikey boy part of me
wonders if this date isn't even real and
as of right now it's just a little
placeholder and then once movies like
free guy and chung chi which are going
to be the big determining factors
whether studios decide to put out their
movies in the next couple of months if
shang chi and free guy do good at the
box office they might go ahead and move
it up a little bit but if they bomb and
make a little bit of money like
unfortunately that's what it's looking
like for those two films is that they're
looking to underperform then they have
an excuse to be like all right we tried
now this is gonna be going all the way
to next year uh he makes a solid point
there about how they're not gonna move
halloween kills at all i think the first
venom it did come out during october and
i feel like for what the film venom is
or let there be carnage october is an
appropriate time to release the movie
but there's no way they're going to move
halloween kills that's just not going to
happen it makes more sense for halloween
kills to keep the release date more than
it does for venom to put it out there uh
during that time period and i wish they
were like we're in a time right now
where i feel like the studios kind of
need to work together just a little bit
just a tiny tiny bit competition is
something that is not you know something
new to the movie industry but to put it
out right around the same time or at the
same exact time it's like come on no we
need to give each movie some time we
need to give it time
please just separate it and uh he might
have a good idea about the placeholder
but free guy and chongqi shanxi way more
than free guy is going to be a strong
determining factor to whether or not
venom will stick to this release date
better be a success shang chi
this is honestly such a ridiculous
decision and it sucks but man it also
makes me wonder about all these other
sony movies because no way is spider-man
no way home safe this is why we have not
been getting a trailer for spider-man no
way home is because sonya does not want
to waste those marketing dollars like
they just wasted for two phantom
trailers with some correct dates or not
even proper dates on their movies
letting the public know about this film
and now that excitement that hype that
we had for it is gonna die out if we
have to wait for this movie till next
year or even october basically
spider-man no way home is in very big
trouble and it's looking very likely
like we might not see spider-man until
next summer guys they're not gonna push
spider-man no way home until like
february or march notes
it's gonna be till june or july where
most spider-man movies usually like to
come out i feel like may would be okay
yeah especially if it came out yeah
especially if toby maguire is in this
you know it would be cool if they didn't
honor that with me i would hope that
would be perfect it would be a good time
for that nostalgic factor for those who
give a damn about things like that plus
that'll be the biggest summer box office
and then people will be able to say like
oh man post pandemic it was a huge
upswing and spiderman saved it all chris
makes a good point about the marketing
that cost them a lot of money to put
those things together it costs them a
lot so not only are they going to want
to make sure that when they release this
movie they're going to make their money
back
for what it costs to just make the movie
they're going to want to make sure
that they're making their money back on
what it costs to make the marketing and
not make the money back but profit
significantly you know so the delays
make sense to me it's just risky times
right now that we're living and and uh
yeah the pandemic is i i have a
suspicion we are i don't want to say it
i wouldn't be surprised if we are down
to a temporary lockdown against stay at
home orders yeah or at least a lot of
the bigger events getting pushed and
postponed for sure i can't be doing six
more months of spider-man intros but you
guys hear this yeah you can
you got it in you buddy
that's what i live for chris let there
be carnage what do you guys think of all
this nonsense sony will not be putting
it on streaming so don't even put them
comments down there the real money is in
theaters and that's what they're holding
out hope for don't forget to like
subscribe follow me on twitter at 3c
film review as always i'm chris take
care thanks for reporting the news there
buddy solid points oh yeah because you
don't want to wind up doing like what
tennant did and like printing up like
hundreds of posters for like three
different release dates none of which
are ever going to be the actual one
black widow
yeah all right guys well how do you feel
about this news are you at all surprised
we'll see you guys
[Music]
you